es gibt einen neuen wirklich
aussichtsreichen kandidaten für die
mysteriöse dunkle materie die rede ist
von sogenannten hexa quarks die bereits
in der vergangenheit in
teilchenbeschleunigern nachgewiesen
werden konnten können wir das größte
rätsel der modernen physik jetzt schon
bald lösen krieg zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
windows abonniert den karat und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen die dunkle
materie ist wohl das größte rätsel der
modernen physik dunkle materie ist
unsichtbar
sie sendet weder licht aus noch
reflektiert sie dieses noch nie hat sie
jemand gesehen gehen direkter nachweis
steht also bis heute aus dennoch ist
dieser stoff wohl entscheidend für alles
was überhaupt existiert denn dunkle
materie macht schätzung zufolge bis zu
27 prozent des universums aus hinzu
kommen noch knapp 69 prozent dunkle
energie die normale sichtbare materie im
universum also alle galaxien sterne und
eben auch wir machen dagegen nur einen
bruchteil von 4,9 prozent aus und obwohl
sie nicht direkt sichtbar ist macht sich
dunkle materie indirekt eben schon
bemerkbar und zwar durch ihre
gravitation die ganze galaxien um sich
gruppiert und die auseinander fliegen
würden wenn es den dunkle materie nicht
gäbe den gängigen theorien zufolge ist
dunkle materie also durch ihre wirkung
als eine art klebstoff dafür
verantwortlich dass wir überhaupt
existieren so sieht es jedenfalls die
absolute mehrheit in der astrophysik
doch wie genau setzt sie sich zusammen
ein forschungsteam aus jork ist fest
davon überzeugt dass wir bislang auf der
falschen spur waren denn es gibt viele
teilchen die in frage kommen mit dabei
unter anderem die sogenannten wiki
interacting massive particles kurzfilms
die aktion und die sterile neutrinos
doch bisher keine treffer die englischen
fachleute haben jetzt aber einen anderen
aussichtsreichen kandidaten ausgemacht
und zwar das sogenannte hexa quark im d
23 80 wie der name schon sagt also ein
teilchen aus sechs quarks diese
exotischen teilchen sind nicht neu erste
hinweise auf diesen sechs marktzustand
hatte schon ein experiment mit dem cosi
beschleuniger des forschungszentrums
jülich im jahr 2011
und genau diese teilchen haben jetzt das
interesse der fachleute aus jork geweckt
unsere ersten kalkulationen deuten
darauf hin dass kondensator von d
sternchen teilchen plausible kandidaten
für die dunkle materie sind vereinfacht
gesagt handelt es sich bei quarks um die
sehr kleinen teilchen aus denen protonen
und neutronen bestehen ja und diese
wiederum bilden ja teile der atome somit
handelt es sich um die grundbausteine
der materie und ein extra quark würde
dann ähnlich wie protonen und neutronen
aus quarks bestehen in protonen und
neutronen sind die beiden leichtesten
quark sorten typischer weise miteinander
kombiniert dort forschungsteams weltweit
konnten in den vergangenen jahren auch
andere quarks paarungen erzeugen das
geht mit hilfe von
teilchenbeschleunigern und so entstanden
beispielsweise teilchen mit schweren
quarks oder auch teilchen aus 45 eben
oder sogar sechs quarks und genau die
sind super spannend für die wissenschaft
das forschungsthema york hat eben jetzt
das hick-hack warten die sternchen 23 80
genauer ins visier genommen denn
möglicherweise ist es bestandteil der
mysteriösen dunklen materie und das ist
tatsächlich eine kleine sensation denn
die dunkle materie ist wie schon
angedeutet eines der größten rätsel der
modernen physik kommen der er jetzt
endlich auf die schliche
nach ansicht des forschungsteams aus
jork ist denkbar dass sich die lange
gesuchten teilchen der dunklen materie
in einem bestimmten zustand des hexa
cores de sternchen 23 80 verbergen die
fachleute wissen dass sich das exakt wie
ein person verhält damit ist gemeint
dass sich mehrere dieser teilchen im
selben kranken zustand befinden können
so sind sie gekoppelt und bilden quasi
eine große einheit dadurch sind sie viel
stabiler als es die einzelnen teilchen
für sich alleine sind also bisschen
ähnlich wie beim atom kann man sich das
vorstellen
zudem weiß man dass diese personen
ähnlichen teilchen doppelt so schwer wie
ein neutron oder ein proton sind diese
struktur dieser teilchen ist super
komplex und sie bestehen aus drei down
quarks und 3 ab quax doch vor allem die
fähigkeit dieser teilchen eine große
einheit zu bilden und somit sehr stabil
zu sein ist ein spannender aspekt für
die wissenschaft so ein kondensat könnte
riesig sein
also viel größer als an
und sich durch die kopplung wie ein
einziges teilchen verhalten also neben
bose einstein kondensat bei dem
einzelnen teilchen zu einem großen ja zu
einem teilchen quasi verschmelzt
jedenfalls werden sie einst sie sind die
einzelnen teilchen in diesem kondensat
nicht mehr zu lokalisieren und verhalten
sich eben quasi wie ein riesiges monster
teilchen verrückt doch wie stabil sind
diese kondensate wirklich und könnten
diese teilchen auch in einem sehr frühen
kosmos in großer menge entstehen genau
diesen fragen sind die vorstellungen aus
jork auf die spur gegangen und die
ergebnis ist eindeutig ihre modell liegt
nahe dass bereits kondensat aus rund
1000 solcher teilchen stabil genug sein
könnten um sie zu grundbausteinen der
dunkle materie zu machen die dunkle
materie uns den heutigen vorstellungen
zufolge zusammen mit der normalen
materie entstanden sein und zwar nach
dem urknall als sich das junge universum
so langsam abkühlt in der aktuellen
studie wird deutlich dass die
rahmenbedingungen damals die bildung von
hexer quax tatsächlich in großer anzahl
ermöglicht haben können diese ergebnisse
machen forschen den weltweit große
hoffnung der dunklen materie doch noch
auf die schliche zu kommen doch noch ist
es zu früh sich zu freuen denn der
endgültige nachweis dass diese hacks
tatsächlich die teilchen der dunklen
materie sind steht noch aus ein dazu
passendes experiment ist mit den
heutigen teilchenbeschleunigern nicht
möglich dennoch sind wir nicht in der
lage genügend hexa quax herzustellen um
diese dann in ein stabiles kondensat zu
bringen und so setzen die fachleute auf
die verräterische gammastrahlung die
nämlich frei wird wenn die hexa
kondensate zerfallen dazu schreibt das
autorenteam daher können wir die
existenz der hexa quark kondensate nur
über ihre astrophysikalische signatur
bestätigen von einem solchen kondensat
kollaps würde man eine lokalisierte und
quasi instanz eine emission von
gammastrahlung mit einem intensiven
fluss von drohnen nuklearen und
geladenen ionen erwarten doch nach
ansicht des forschungsteams gamer ist
zudem auch eine weitere möglichkeit
hinweise auf die teilchen zu bekommen
und zwar sogar von der erde aus
die rede ist von einem speziellen typ
kosmischer strahlung die sogar die erde
passieren könnte und von unten in
speziellen detektoren einlaufen würde
diese müssten dann genau analysiert
werden um
die hexa quark kondensate astronomische
einzugrenzen und hinweise auf ihre
eigenschaften zu bekommen dazu heißt es
in der studie
die zurzeit laufenden und noch geplanten
röntgen und gammastrahlung observatorien
könnten limit für die existenz der de
sternchen 23 18 kondensate setzen
superschwere elemente die jagd nach
neuer materie anklicken anschauen und
doktor watson abonnieren übrigens kleine
rätselfrage für die kommentare auf
welchem kanal liefen die ersten doktor
watson videos bis dann bleibt dran